can you rank the e-boys on who makes the
best
[Laughter]
oh that's a good question um
[Music]
what was the first video you uploaded to
youtube
well when i was like 11 years old i'd
make videos with like my friends in the
park just us like messing around but my
first video on the channel i run at the
moment it was just an edit of like a low
budget film
[Music]
it didn't really take off
but that was the first video on this
channel
so at that point in time were you doing
it because you wanted to be a youtuber
honestly it was just for fun um because
i i had a channel before and it had like
a few thousand subs and at that point i
was like oh i could probably try and
turn this into a job
and i got so sick of trying to do that
try and make it a career i just made a
channel for like just the fun of it
and ironically that's the one that ended
up being my job
there was a period where my channel was
just slowly bubbling up and i'd be
making about probably about 30 pounds a
day
and i'd be looking at that and thinking
oh that's nearly a grand a month that's
like what i get a part-time job at tesco
or something but then when i made a
video it was my first proper like banger
video and i remember looking at the
real-time graph and being like what has
happened is someone giving me a shout
out or something and it was just this
video that blew up um it was on um
little t uh it was on little t and
sophie aspen if anyone remembers uh that
little t has been beefing with this girl
called sophie aspen
let's get into little t who you are so
fast been sent sophie yes we know who
you are
sophie yeah you're
[Music]
that's an intimidating location i mean
is there anywhere more intimidating than
your local kebab shop when i made that
video
on my like earnings i had like a day
where i made like a hundred pounds
and then it kind of averaged out about
like 60 from there on so i was like oh
wow i could actually make this like a
viable job now
the amount you post is pretty relentless
do you ever suffer from burnout i've
wanted to be a youtuber like it's like
an absolute dream job and i don't want
to see it slip away so that's the kind
of thing that keeps me going and keep
uploading i try and work through burnout
because i just want to do this as i just
want to do this so much but burnout for
me i is where i don't upload for like a
week and a half i basically try and
upload at least once a week on my main
channel and then uh at least like two
three times in my second i feel as
though that's pressure i put on myself
but i don't know i i don't i'd i'd
always like to try and upload more i
always try and find like new things to
talk about like
as of recent i've been uh doing um like
reactions to like uh films and tv shows
um
and those that's like kind of the newish
thing i've been doing at the time of
this recording epic movie is apparently
supposed to be better than disaster
movie but not by much it's still 13th on
the imdb bottom 100s so um i haven't got
high hopes to say the least my hopes are
through the floor in fact my hypes are
so far through the floor they're at the
molten core of the earth so
realistically there's not really any way
which this could disappoint me
what do your parents make of what you do
for a living i never really told them
for like the first like few years i was
doing it because i was just i was
embarrassed i didn't want to making fun
of me but it wasn't until i hit like
100k my brother came in the room and he
was like hello meme you know sounds like
what and he uh it's because his uh
friends on xbox have found my channel uh
because and they're like oh this guy
sounds like your brother
um and then he went and told my parents
and my parents was like oh hello i
missed the internet
and they were making fun of me and then
uh they're like do you make money off
this then i was like yeah i made about
like 80 to 100 pounds a day at the
moment and they were like oh wow okay
so you can do this as a job now
yeah
obviously one of your big visual
features is the concealment of your
identity where did that decision come
from uh it wasn't necessarily really a
decision in the beginning it was just i
didn't feel it necessary to show my face
but then it kind of just spiraled and
became its own thing in its own brand i
guess so something that's really put me
off like ever showing my face was uh
like sometimes when i go on nights out
with like friends who have youtube
channels uh you see like drunken people
like
go up and grab them and drag them and
basically like treat them like property
it's really really like off-putting
to someone who's watching this video uh
who's never seen
me meliss before
which one video would be the gateway
drug i'd say like the the reactions to
like tv shows and fit like one of them
videos because i think those are
probably some of the best stuff i've
ever made
love island something i have missed very
dearly during the pandemic it's back and
i watched the first episode and the
first episode only and i was not
impressed to say the least have you seen
it you've watched that over the footy no
i watched both of them i i tweeted about
out about love island people oh
technically i've got one both at the
same time i do i did like iron man
because i have two monitors i have two
monitors and i'm totally stuck all right
in some of your content famously you
roast people on other channels
however any of them ever got upset by it
or come after you no no no the funny
thing is like that a lot of them take it
really well because they realize like
i'm not out to like
like am i out to swear yeah i'm not out
to shoot them basically i'm not like um
out to take them down it's more just
like
a laugh it's for entertainment you know
i mean so it's like um
i've i've met a lot of the people i've
made videos on and they've been like
really um
uh i guess uh respectful uh as a way to
say said but are they i don't know i've
never had anyone like confront me in
person because that'd be a bit weird why
would you confront someone over a
youtube video in real life
who are some of the other current
youtubers you admire
i'll tell you who i am at the moment um
it's like uh i don't know if you guys
have seen but the the minecraft a lot uh
like there's uh there's guys that are
that like 16 years old and they've got
like nearly 10 million subscribers it's
just insane like
how like well they're doing at that age
and how well they're handling it
they're people i look up to quite a lot
just because of like
how well they've done in such a short
amount of time
and looking at the flip of it what do
you think is some of the worst stuff on
youtube at the moment
oh god it's like um have you seen them
like investment uh
channels not like there's some good ones
but then there's some that's like oh
dogecoin is gonna go to five dollars
it's not it's not they're like selling
you a dream like there's just like and
the ones that try and sell you courses
like they are the app they're not just
on youtube they're on like tick tock and
stuff as well they are the absolute
worst
one of the current trends at the moment
is essentially youtubers fighting each
other yeah um what do you think of that
um
i think it's good entertainment like
seeing uh especially like the the jj
logan stuff that was probably one of the
highlights of 2019 seeing him win um
but it's seeing like uh all the tick
tockers and stuff come through now and
try and fight each other and it's like
you don't we've like jj and logan you've
been watching them for years and you've
watched them come up through like
youtube and stuff slowly and uh you've
kind of built a connection to at least
one of them if you watch youtube so
you're kind of like back it you've got
someone to back but whereas when it's
tick tockers who have like become big in
like the last six months to a year you
just don't care
do trolls bother you
if that's your job and something you put
a lot of work into you like it's gonna
get anyone down but uh as of recent i
i've kind of stopped checking my social
media just because i've realized like
i'd be sat on it all day like checking
what everyone said i could get 100 nice
things sent to me and then that one bad
thing would make me i'd be thinking
about that all day i still have the apps
and everything but i just don't really
check uh what people are saying about me
as much
which i think is
is more as a more healthy thing to do
i've definitely been like happier in
that respect of things since doing it
more recently there's been a lot of
rumors flying around about what happened
to the e-boys can you give us the real
reason
uh the real reason is what has been put
on youtube like it was a case of i think
we were all not really feeling it as
much like we all wanted to kind of do
our own things more and will was kind of
just like look i'm really not happy
doing this like i don't i don't want to
do it anymore and then we were me alex
and james were just like
we don't want to do it without will so
there's like no point so we just like
called it quits and that that's it
that's it it was it was a fun year i
don't regret doing it it was good fun uh
a lot of good memories
can you rank the e-boys on who makes the
best
[Laughter]
uh um
uh i gotta put you gotta put will at the
top
because um
his stuff is just great um
and then
i'd put james and alex tied and then me
at the bottom
if you could go back to yourself
when you were very first starting out
what would you say to yourself oh that's
a good question um
i think it will be like um
okay uh
like thumbnails and titles you gotta
focus on like what what people want to
click on make the videos engaging
throughout uh good equipment cause i
remember for a while i was using like
this really crap mic for like uh this is
after i did like mlg edits i just i had
this really crap mic and it sounded
really bad so um
i you get get good equipment uh just to
make your videos look good
yeah you just got to keep out if you
want to get somewhere with youtube it's
like it's a it's a game of like
persistence
like if you do it for like six months
then give up chances are you're not
going to make it but then if you do it
for like five six years like
persistently chances are you're going to
have like some form of success
diversifying your income it just makes
you it's like a safety net it makes you
feel secure um
and also i think investing in general
like even if you just have like a normal
job is like pretty beneficial
do you think that being a youtuber is
something young people should aspire to
a lot of people see it as this thing
that's really out of reach but i feel as
though if a lot a lot of people if they
like dedicate time to it and years to it
like consistently the more you work on
it the more likely it is to pay off like
i don't know if this is just me
but everyone i know that has put their
mind to youtube but i've known a lot of
people not a single one of them that put
their mind to it for years has isn't
doing it full time at the moment which
is quite i find quite interesting maybe
it's just me
you're not gonna it's very very rare
that you're gonna make your first video
and then you're gonna become a youtube
celebrity like it's like it takes years
to figure out like what does well what
holds retention what is a good thumbnail
what is a good title it takes years to
learn these things like
you kind of just got to look at why your
best videos did best
i think it's more about just learning
you can never really be true friends
after something like that i just don't
think it can ever ever happen maybe if
you
fought and it was a draw
maybe you could still be friends but the
idea of being friends with someone that
has a beating you it's a hard thing for
your head to compute